i had no intention of becoming a
production designer i intend to be to be
an academic
but i was working in new york for a
photographer
and
a friend of mine said would you come
down and take some pictures with and i
said sure and i went down
and i'm looking around and i see this
woman fiddling with something in the in
the corner over there and i said what is
she doing i said they said she's a
production designer i said what is that
and it was like a lightning bolt when
they described the job because it
studied architecture i was a good
photographer
somehow i thought this is the job for me
so i hounded michael houseman
for about six months and then he gave me
a job and i had absolutely no skills
whatsoever
but i learned fast
and a production designer has a lot of
production things that they have to do
you have to sort things out with the
money with there is so much more than
just designing i feel that the design
part is almost for me the simple part
it's follow-through everything is
through it's all very good to have a
great building and a great idea but if
you can't get it in front of the camera
the way you want it
then you're wasting your time
well on my first experience i was the
designer and the costume designer and
the makeup lady i don't know i mean it's
changed dramatically i think uh in the
last few years because of the
the visual effects and computer
generated effects and the fact that you
don't always know what the final
the final look of the film will be when
you're done and that to me i think is is
the most
uh
the most difficult thing for me to deal
with because i know what my work looks
like but i won't know what the added
work will look like and i find that some
that's a confusing thing for me